from a good spot as Thompson walks the line
works it over for Palm below the goal line
Barelle looking over his options connects to
Nelson toson one timer rebound there Barelle
couldn't get it back on that great pass from Brock
Nelson to engal and couldn't find the corner or
couldn't elevate it it came pretty quick pretty
hard but what an opportunity that was Islanders
coming again Nelson in shoot SC [Applause] [Music]
oh you've seen that one a time or two Nelson's got
his second tremendous transition Brendon I mean
the Islanders came up had a nice three on two
hit him on the left side so Islanders getting
up in a hurry good pass Ryan Pollock there's
Paul Mary through the middle drive through and
Brock Nelson he just doesn't miss from there he
knows where he wants to go and he can put it
there he's a sharpshooter just whistles that
one past the goal tender well they had a couple
of good opportunities and this line continues to
have terrific chemistry I don't know if that was a
planned play or not but it worked out pretty well
look out here's Hughes in Al trying to settle it
and it's Zin who comes up with the answer oh wow
from The Islander [Applause] goenda green now in
charge of this Devil's power play as team o Meer
comes in curls away from AO sets up Hamilton and
he scores douge Hamilton with a heavy one-time
that gets through soken and the devil's tyeing
on the power play yeah just a great great play
talk about teing the puckup watch in the middle
of your screen there's Hamilton a right-hander
Meer looks him up and he just wires that thing
and I talked about soken being able to get set
set no chance to get set there he was on his way
out five hole I believe that I like to have been
in the dressing room between that period cuz
I'm sure Lane Lambert had plenty to say that
was the worst period of hockey the Islanders had
played as far as I'm concerned and mind you they
haven't played many seven periods but that was
not a very good period for him they have the
ultimate equalizer in net and ilas sokin which
is the reason it's a 1-1 score could have been
341 perhaps as Hughes carries in now to Foley
the Foley weit shoot scores that one ramped up
off the Stick of Adam pelic and jumped over
the shoulder of sokin a power play goal just
21 seconds into the period Tyler T's first goal as
a devil and look at look at the speed through the
neutral zone cross ice passes Islanders almost
get it down and then the Quick Pass to huge and
he's able to get it the quick passes and then to
Foley with a great wrist shot and he's found a
home there I guess why wouldn't you you mentioned
it brenon right off the stick it looks to me of
of Adam pelic and right over the shoulder so you
know he's fairly motivated this year you case he
likes to contribute and not only from a checking
standpoint but offensively had that one what 20
goal season and finished last year with none in
his last 27 here's Nelson alone [Applause] scores
happy Brock over to all who celebrate Nelson's
got a pair tonight I win that draw and they're
going to go down around the boards with it and
again good hard work along the boards here's the
turnover and Brock slides into the slot look at
the patience and then he just Waits gets his head
up and says okay what's open watch him lift his
head takes a little look says okay I got a five
hole there I can see him spreading his legs
that is a gifted goal score Hughes to Hughes
to to Foley Luke Hughes plays it now for Brad
they quickly find 86 in Jack Hughes Luke Hughes
winds up and shoots and scores all the attention
on Jack Hughes it's his little brother Luke who
finds the back of the net the third power play
goal tonight for New Jersey that's huge on your
left as he comes around and then his brother
right in the area so let's just see if that's
OHA soken was screened he was looking left and
didn't have a chance to really pick that one up
you can see no chance yeah that's brat in front
of the net and cikas goes down and that that's
just the perfect shot Martin for Clutterbuck too
hot to handle that that was good pass by Martin to
clutter and clutter just had bounced off his stick
a little bit but good try Martin feeds doson down
low and they [Applause] score doson with a good
look to Horvat along the goal line tough angle
no problem tied at three real Sharpshooter good
play by Noah doson Defender watch Matty Martin
gets the puck hangs on to it takes a little look
here comes Noah doson moving in and the fake and
boy there just wasn't any room there well I guess
there was beautiful shot by Horvat as he just off
the pad and in good car no hesitation and Bo
needed that one badly that'll help him this one
out for Sean ther goes wide of the net picked up
by Bastion Bastion angles it Hamilton cross the
ice Sean ther snaps one tip down rebound it's
soken another Sensational save zanol gets this
thing right toward towards the net and look
at Bastion and there there's a sliding across
pad down flat I mean talk about the ability to be
able to flex those legs and he just makes that sa
he even had the glove up a little higher just in
case he needed to use the glove but he's got it in
position got the L Schmid at the other end hasn't
been any anywhere near is busy so the Islanders
will probably be looking to put a little more
pressure on the golender at the devil's end but
at the same time when Barry trotz was coaching the
capitals it's been that [Applause] long Mr oetkin
certainly had something to do with it I'm sure he
did pass in front and they score again it's Jack
Hughes on the power play Four Power Play Goals for
New Jersey as they take the lead here in the third
that one took 28 seconds to find the back of the
net you watch the bottom of your screen where Ryan
poock is are going to look watch poot he's going
to look for it they're going to go back and forth
and he just come sliding right in and I'm not sure
about the positioning there whether that's cikas
or of course Ryan poock but you you've got to know
where your guys are and that's that goes right
through the crease and there's no doubt to me but
120 to go empty net for New York extra attacker on
trying to to tie the score Paul maray shoots save
Schmid rebound Schmid it's in ball Horvat followed
it up and knocked it home to tie the score guys he
was yelling for that puck the second it got over
the Blue Line we'll take another look at it but he
wanted this Puck and he went and found it SPS out
little slide over to Paul Mary and he just gets
it towards the net little rebound off the glove
and there follow it right up a fuit is bounc but
everybody at the net Anders Lee and the Islanders
finally get a break the Devils were yelling
at the officials saying that should have been
a hand pass by Matt barzel we've taken a couple
looks at it that would be a tough Challenge and
has tied this score each team with a goal here in
the third period Devils got one early Islanders
get one late two goals for Nelson two goals for
Horvat 32 two saves for sokin and we are not done
yet the Islanders first overtime game of this
young season Nelson pelic and Paul Mary on the
ice against Jack Hughes Luke Hughes and
Jesper Brack and McLoud was just out for
the face off and Brock Nelson won the face
off so and then McLoud went off right away
PA Mary drops Nelson had it poked away two
on one up the ice as Nelson tries to hustle
back Jack Hughes in shoot save soken Marino
out high and it comes to [Applause] Center
Marino chased back into his own end sets it
up for Jack Hughes fresh on to the ice Jack
Hughes waiting for Luke it's Hughes he scores
Jack Hughes does it himself a 5-4 overtime win
for the Devils the Islanders just gave him way
too much room they had an opportunity to close
him down right away and traic shot by Hughes
as he went to the forehand and beat he soken